Here's one way of doing that. Say, I want to take three
breaks throughout the day. I will use the break count variable to
keep count of the number of breaks I've taken. And then
add a while loop, to make sure that this code runs three
times. By the way, if you want to see some information on
how while loops work, there is a helpful link in the instructor
notes. Now, if I run this program. The program will wait
for ten seconds and play the song and do that three times.
Another handy addition to our program can be a print
statement that tells us when our program began. Now, how
do I find the current time? When I have to
do some testing like this, I start to use this
output window, so I can import time here. Which, as
you may guess, is a way to access time. And
I know there is a function called ctime, or current
time. That seems like the current time on my computer. Great.
Back to the main program where I'll add this. Let me save and run this program.
Now, as soon as I run the program, I get a prompt, suggesting when I started the
program. Ten seconds after that, a video
is played which asks me to take a break
[MUSIC].
So far so good. Another ten seconds pass
by and another suggestion to take a break.
[MUSIC]
Now, if I want to stop this program
midway, I can either restart IDLE or use Ctrl+C
in the shell window, which will stop the execution
of the program when it comes back from sleep.